[Music]
is with us
in hughes arkansas hey what's up
hello dave hello ken good nice to speak
to both of you
you too okay i'm sorry i'm a first time
caller so i'm like no troubles man how
can we help
um i have a couple questions so
i am currently five thousand three
hundred and sixty dollars in
student loan debt and i plan on moving
out of my parents house
by next year around this time
and um i currently work at walmart
and i probably make around like 1500 a
month
and i was i was saying if it would be
smart for me
to um go get a factory job in the same
area
it'll practically double my income but
my only concern with that is um
is because it's not an essential job
like when the
shutdown first happened in arkansas it
was closed down for like
four or five months so i was just
trying to get your thoughts on it so
your concern is if you go get a second
job
and it's non-essential that it could go
away is that what i'm hearing
no it's my new charges right
um if i just leave walmart and go do the
factory job
okay well i think you should go do the
job
that is going to double the income so
yes i think you should do that because
you've got an opportunity to pay off a
very small amount of debt
fifty three hundred dollars you're going
to move out your goal is to move out a
year from now i think you could do that
much faster
i absolutely would take it tell me why
you're asking that is there some
concerns you have about taking the
factory job
uh just just because at the beginning of
pandemic it was closed down
sure well you know you can't really
control things like that that was out of
your control that was out of
in some ways their control back then i
think that uh
with the rise of the uh
uh vaccine and i think with the economy
is on its way back we're now at 6.3
percent
unemployment if you look at the
nationwide numbers
i don't think you can make a decision
based on the fear of what could happen
there because you've done a good job
of showing up at walmart you found
hourly work and you could do that again
but this is an opportunity if it's right
there in front of you
unless there's some other reason why you
shouldn't do it this is a no-brainer go
do it pay off that debt
quickly and save up so that a year from
now you know you've got the baby steps
in order you've got your emergency fund
and then you can
step right into your own apartment or
your home whatever you're going to do
there so yeah take it
absolutely and then that's not the last
decision you make in your entire life
now you start looking for okay what is
my long-term career
and what am i going to move towards
because it might not be at the factory
it might be but i don't want you to end
up 30 years from now still
still there because you never bothered
to sit down and look at what you're
supposed to be doing
you know and some things along those
lines